justin trudeau being accused of tyranny
for his heavy-handed approach to crack
down on the trucker protest the prime
minister invoking never before used
emergency powers to try and stop the
freedom convoy after being pressured by
president biden
we are not limiting people's freedom of
speech we are not limiting freedom of
peaceful assembly we are not preventing
people from exercising their right to
protest legally
we are reinforcing
the principles values and institutions
that keep all canadians
free
the canadian government also going after
the truckers money by threatening to
freeze protesters personal bank accounts
if they do not comply
this is about
following the money
this is about stopping the financing of
these illegal blockades
if your truck is being used in these
illegal blockades
your corporate accounts will be frozen
the insurance on your vehicle will be
suspended
send your semi-trailers home
and trudeau expanding money laundering
and quote terrorism financing rules that
deal with online fundraising protesters
our client at power grab but trudeau is
not backing off i mean there is another
alternative jesse like they could talk
to the truckers and maybe come to some
sort of they don't negotiate with
terrorists the provinces are already
peeling back these mandates right yeah
they said trump had a thing for
dictators what does trudeau have he's
got a little bit more than a thing here
this is what happens during the pandemic
they kind of discovered these emergency
powers that were tucked away into their
constitutions and so now they just
declare everything in emergency and then
voila emergency power
compare everything to a threat or say
anybody is racist boom anti-terror laws
and that's the problem this is a sad day
for north america and we've had many sad
days here in north america we're not
subjects you can't rule us by force
trudeau was doing the right thing up
until this point in terms of action not
in terms of language he was letting this
play out peacefully and that was going
someplace i think until biden got on the
horn and pressured him to
throw down against his own citizens
congrats justin you're the first foreign
leader to ever listen to biden good luck
with that
these banks
i'm disgusted with this freeze yeah
could you imagine you're a client of a
bank and they freeze your assets because
you're participating in civil
disobedience i wouldn't be surprised if
i saw a run on some of these banks i
wouldn't be surprised if people just
liquidated their assets put it into
another deposit to her because this is
disgusting imagine you're a bank
president how nauseous you would feel
taking an order from some low-life
politician to freeze assets of your own
clientele your neighbors that you
probably donated to yeah yeah and then
so i mean come on you're supposed to
treat them like terrorists these people
your own countrymen that's horrible and
this isn't jihad this is what peaceful
protest should be about gandhi did it
the civil rights movement did it they
just sat down and said deal with me and
that's what you're supposed to do and
this is what we want people to do when
they have a beef with the government so
i wish a hex on canada i hope they have
a terrible maple syrup season and i hope
their hockey team loses all the rest of
their games this year you might want to
check in with greg about how that goes
in canada hey do you know what justin
trudeau is not a very talented
politician no because if biden called if
i were justin trudeau and biden called
me and told me to pressure that might
say fine could we have keystone pipeline
back oh see that's remember that was the
first day and he didn't do it yeah you
know i'm going to go back at my initial
point when this started i am pro trucker
love the semis pro canada
but as an outside observer i should
always respect the country because i
don't want a canadian greg gutfeld
demanding change in my country even if
like me he's 100 right and devilishly
handsome but i'm always like careful i
got to remember that it's easy for us
because we're here we're not there so
there might be some things we don't know
about that we have to wait and see
having said that to you you're right
this isn't a trucker problem
it's not even a canadian problem it's a
one-person problem and it's the one
person is trudeau he got off on the
wrong foot he he chose the deplorable
foot instead of persuading he denigrated
and he dug a hole for himself that's
beginning to look like a political grave
because i don't think he has the
gumption to admit that he
should start over like you know maybe
it's time to start but if you look at
him i was you know making jokes while we
were watching him his stat his stature
has shrunk he's like a he's not a prime
minister he's like a bass player in a
cruise ship wedding band he's a
teacher's assistant
in gender studies at a local college you
know he's a tour guide at universal
studios who's never around if he's the
prime minister of canada then so is
shaggy from scooby-doo this guy is done
and the thing is i think he is done
because
the amazing thing is he's responding to
a cry for freedom and it could have been
very easy like the mandates are done
we're good have like but he didn't he
went deploy he went full deplorable and
you never go full deplorable ask hillary
you never do that judge you know the
idea that trudeau came out and he said
look what i want to do is i want to keep
canadians safe and they are harming the
economy and they are endangering public
safety no they're not they're sitting
there and they're just protesting and
the amazing part of it is trudeau is now
going to listen to biden biden now has
the final word on what you should do if
someone is protesting peacefully biden
the same guy who in the summer of 2020
decided that he would allow people to
burn down you know streets and
businesses and and create all kinds of
problems and arson and criminal acts and
police injured so biden's going to call
this guy who is dumb enough to listen to
him and the saddest part of it is you
know when they start going after
people's money understand these truckers
work very hard they are assault of the
earth
and they are not people who have a lot
of money they can't afford to protest
they really can't but they're all about
freedom they're the heroes that we loved
when we needed all of those things
delivered to us
now you're marginalizing them now you're
really teeing them off they haven't done
anything there isn't any kind of problem
other than the you know then maybe
somebody had a flag well that's going to
happen in any group but i think that
this is going to get worse before it
gets better okay one thing i was also
thinking about this uh i want to get
your take on the financial piece in the
time we have but also
the fact that
these truckers
and all the other essential employees
were essential while everyone else that
got to work from home
waited for their deliveries was they
were able to go to the grocery store
then all of a sudden on january 15th
with the stroke of a pen all of a sudden
they're non-essential and all these
other rules apply to them and i think
that was a straw that broke the camel's
back give you a chance to talk about
that but also do you have thoughts on
the fact that these about going after
their money so i'm not bothered by this
like you guys are for this reason
they you have every right to express
yourself
you have every right to to engage in
civil disobedience but when you break
the law you're going to get arrested
when dr king broke the law he got he
went to jail he wrote his second most
important document the letter from the
birmingham jail it wasn't from the
birmingham convenience store
these guys here
i look i don't necessarily agree with
them not wanting to get the vaccine but
they have every right to protest but
when you interrupt and disrupt commerce
when you infringe upon this called
tortuous interference the judge knows
this as well this is what they've done
arrested on that but you can't freeze
their bank no no but but jesse you know
we've been on the show we don't want
people some people don't want to even
arrest them i'm just saying follow the
law i'm a rule of law guy now if you
believe that the vaccine mandate stuff
should be reverse entry don't go go to
court
go elect new people to the parliament or
whatever you call it there and go
unelect justin trudeau
now when the people were protesting
against george floyd and they were
breaking into stores and they were
engaging in violence i was on this
network saying those people should be
arrested those people should be held
accountable i came out saying defund the
police very early was one of the dumbest
reactions to any political crisis that
we face this here you can't be partial
about the law because you like what
they're doing
it's about the banking they should be
frozen harold that's what this is about
you don't do that but
if they broke the law you can't use your
accounts it's their law there in canada
i don't know
terrorism law for the first time ever
right so he should be unelected they're
not terrorists they are not terrorists
they bring me cabbage
i would say that that is terrorism after
you eat it that's true they have caused
a hundred million dollars a day in the
last few days of damage to the car now
i'm not saying you can disagree with me
on that but justin trudeau decided to
act i think anyone that breaks the law
no matter how they how legitimate or how
uh and genuine they think they're being
about fighting a law if you break the
law you've got to pay the costs if they
if they do get arrested and go to jail i
wonder if somebody on the opposing side
of justin trudeau will offer to pay
their bail that was wrong too maybe the
canadian
yes good pony of some canadian dollars
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else